俺今・・・リュック背負ってるように見えるだろ？
これな…
こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです。
みなさん、ちょうちょ知ってますか？
羽生えてるちょうちょって生き物が結構
世界中でよく見かけられると思うんですけども
そのちょうちょのおもちゃがありまして。
みなさんに今回ご紹介したいと思います。
ザ・マジックバタフライ
近くで見ると結構
えーそれ：・。＠」偽物じゃん
ってなると思うんですけども
遠くから見るとぱっと見ちょうちょなんすよ。
ってことでマジックバタフライがどんなものかといいますと
輪ゴムをくるくるくるっと回す。
で、本とかに挟む。
本を開けた瞬間パタパタパタってちょうちょが
飛んでくやつでございます。
とりあえず一回やってみましょう！
ほんとだけ回すだけでいいんですよ。
で回して、本とかにこうやって挟んで
こうやって何処かに置くと。
で置いた本を開けると
もう一回やろっか。
くるくるくるっと。
閉じて、開けます！
いきましゅ！（いきます！）
あぁ。
まってもっとバタバタいかないの！？
なんで！？
結構がっつりだなこれ…
結構まかなきゃいけないね多分
まきが弱かったのかもしんない
うん これだけまけばたぶん恐ろしい勢いで出てくるんだと思います。
はっ！はっ！はっ！はっ！早い！
これだって遠くからのほうがすごさわかりやすいです。
いきます！スリー、ツー、ワン、
おっほほほほ
はい、というわけで今回このちょうちょを大量に準備しました。
僕は知っているんです。
結局瞬発力のあるものって
面白いということを
というわけで今ここに大量の飛んでくちょうちょがおーっとっとっと待て待て
大量のちょうちょがあるんですけども
これ多分本とかに挟まなくても
ノートパソコンの隙間とかに挟んでおけば飛んでいくと思うんですよ。
ここにあるマジックバタフライをすべて
ノートパソコンのパーって開ける中に全部入れます。ねじって。
で、それを！
ターゲットに渡して
開けたら
こうやって開けた瞬間
パ～って！
ちょうちょが出てきて
わ～！！って
幸せになること間違いなしだと思うので、
ハッピーで、ファンタスティックで、ロマンティックな
素敵な動画になると思います♡
では作ってくよ♡
しゃー！やるぞ！！
ここで難しいのは
今から俺が大量のちょうちょが
全部巻いて巻いて巻いて
ここにいれてくってのはマジ難しいと思うんでちょっと頑張ります
いきます！！！
うわこれむっず！これおくのむず！これおくのむずいよ！
オッケー！
うわ！
あ！
あ！！
あーーーー！！！！！！
いやもうだめだ入んないなこれ
やばいもう物理的限界が迫ってきております
あ、もうむりだ、もう入んないっす。
見えますでしょうか。
マックブックの中に
ひしひしと
ちょうちょが挟まっております。
もう入る余地はありません、ごめんなさい。
待ってこれでもさぁパッと見てすぐわかっちゃうよね
というわけで準備ができました。
早速ターゲットを呼んで、ここに座らして、
パソコンを開いたら
ふわぁ～
ちょうちょたちが
ではいこう！
いってくる。
（話し声）
こっちですこっちです。
はい。
大丈夫ｗｗ
（話し声）
パソコンの中身すげー面白いんで
バッて開けてみてください。
いたくないですよね？
大丈夫大丈夫、パッと！
わああぁぁぁぁ！！！！
（リピート）
笑い声
っしょ。
おー。
まぁまぁまぁ。
えぇうわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁびっくりした。
びっくりした！
笑い声